[Musik]
was denkt und fühlt amerika kurz vor der
präsidentschaftswahl
welche themen treiben die menschen um
was sind ihre ängste ihre hoffnungen
wir hören uns um bei schwarzen und
weißen amerikanern bei jungen und alten
in den städten und auf dem land
die wählerinnen und wähler haben das
wort
[Musik]
der countdown läuft das duell ums weiße
haus steht kurz vor der entscheidung
und diese präsidentschaftswahl wird wohl
als besonders außergewöhnliche in die
geschichte eingehen durch corona krise
wirtschaftskrise und extreme
gesellschaftliche spannungen sind die
usa im ausnahmezustand
der wahlkampf zwischen donald trump und
joe biden ist von aggressiven schrillen
tönen geprägt wie das draußen im land
ankommt haben wir menschen in tennessee
gefragt die sich mit tönen auskennen
melancholie in memphis kaum touristen
wegen corona spielen mac truck und seine
band vor kleinem publikum
[Musik]
sie leben nur von trinkgeldern jeder
dollar ist hart erarbeitet merck sorgt
sich nicht nur um seine existenz sondern
um amerika insgesamt wegen all des
politischen streits klinge das land
gerade wie ein schräg gesungenes lied
mit seiner musik will er das ändern
ich liebe den blues so sehr weil er
immer schon eine großartige vereinigen
der wirkung hat auch früher war die welt
schon mal gespalten
doch der blues hat alles und jeden
zusammengebracht
memphis ist nicht nur die heimat des
blues sondern gilt auch als geburtsort
des rock'n roll hier im legendären sun
studio nahm elvis presley seinen ersten
song auf sein anwesen graceland ist bis
heute eine pilgerstätte für fans
[Musik]
an elvis grab trauert mancher besucher
den guten alten zeiten hinterher
präsident trump werde amerika wieder so
großartig machen wie zu elvis zeiten ist
das ehepaar jenkins überzeugt weil ihnen
ihre heimat kalifornien zu linksliberal
geworden ist wollen sie hierher ins
konservative tennessee ziehen wo trump
viele unterstützer hat ich glaube er
macht einen sehr guten job
er hatte viele seiner versprechen
eingelöst mehr als andere präsidenten in
der vergangenheit hin zu einer politik
stimme ich zu 100 prozent überein
dagegen hält graceland besucherin color
robinson präsident trump für einen
rassisten
es werden immer noch afroamerikaner
unterdrückt dabei hätte es nie einen
elvis presley gegeben ohne schwarze
musik ohne schwarze menschen elvis musik
würde nicht existieren
aber wir kriegen nicht die anerkennung
dafür die wir verdienen
wir werden insgesamt nicht
gleichbehandelt gegenwart und geschichte
des rassismus in den usa sind in memphis
besonders präsent auf diesem balkon des
lorraine hotels stand der bürgerrechtler
martin luther king als er 1968
erschossen wurde heute befindet sich in
dem gebäude ein museum
jaclyn smith hat im low rain hotel
gearbeitet als es geschlossen wurde
landete sie auf der straße seit 32
jahren campiert sie hier jeden tag um zu
protestieren
statt millionen in eine
touristenattraktion zu stecken hätte man
hier ein gemeindezentrum einrichten
können für eine tracklist vermächtnis
von drk sollte sein der menschlichkeit
zu dienen wie er es getan hat
das modell sollte obdachlosen essen und
kleidung nehmen und ein dach über dem
kopf
außerdem sei dieses viertel in dem einst
martin luther king wirkte für schwarze
inzwischen unerschwinglich teuer
geworden beklagt
tatsächlich bestimmen weiße anwohner
inzwischen das bild
[Musik]
tennessee der bundesstaat im süden der
usa ist ländlich geprägt und wird vom
mississippi durchquert unser nächstes
ziel ist die kleine stadt jackson die
der country-sänger johnny cash in einem
song verewigte channel 4 ist nicht nur
für seine musik bekannt sondern auch für
whisky sam bryant lädt uns zu einer
führung durch seine brennerei ein
vor sechs jahren hat sie sich
selbstständig gemacht als das geschäft
gerade endlich gewinn abwarf trafen die
korona krise veranstaltungen finden hier
seit monaten nicht mehr statt deshalb
hofft sie dass trump die wahl gewinnt
und die wirtschaft wieder ankurbeln
rampart viele regulierungen beseitigt
das hat uns sehr geholfen und unsere
steuerlast reduziert falls er verliert
steigen die steuern wieder
ich schätze dass ich bis zu 1800 dollar
pro monat mehr zahlen müsste
dieses geld kann ich dann nicht in die
firma investieren oder ein angestellte
und endlich deutschen immobilien des
merkens double ist glücklich hier einen
arbeitsplatz gefunden zu haben denn
wegen der korona krise hatte sie ihren
job als kellnerin verloren gehen wird
sie nicht wenn sie hält beide kandidaten
nicht für fit genug um das land zu
regieren
ich glaube dass trump verrückt ist wenn
ich sehe was er twittert beiden ist aber
auch nicht ganz dabei in vielen
interviews scheint er die fakten nicht
zu kennen oder weiß nicht worüber er
redet
trump aber auch nicht du musst auch
wissen worüber du spricht hier wird der
whisky produziert
sam erzählt dass viele seiner kunden
gerade von zukunftsängsten geplagt
werden aber manchmal könnten seine
spirituosen eine heilsame wirkung
entfalten ist der unternehmer überzeugt
bisky ist ist es social work whisky ist
ein gesellschaftliches chmielewski kann
zwar böses anrichten wenn man es braucht
aber er kann auch großartiges bewerten
die menschen zusammenbringen und ihnen
schöne erlebnisse beschert
schöne erlebnisse verspricht auch
nashville die welthauptstadt der country
musik erst vor kurzem haben die
unzähligen bars und clubs ihr wieder
eröffnet
[Musik]
rohner scheint fast schon wieder
vergessen die abstandsregeln werden
nicht immer eingehalten
[Musik]
6 4 1 meter 80 auseinander
als dieser song change is holm hat ihn
selbst geschrieben
wie klingt das corona geplagte land so
kurz vor der wahl in seinen ohren klingt
für mich gespielt und einige leute
treiben diese spaltung
mir geht es um einigung ich hoffe dass
wir alle wieder zusammen kommen
doch diese bevorstehende wahl macht alle
nervös und ausgerechnet hier in
nashville haben trump und beiden des tv
duell gegeneinander ausgetragen
shane hatte sich nicht angesehen er hat
lieber in seinem song davon geträumt mit
seiner freundin zu tanzen
aber eben mit 6 fuß abstand
viele amerikanerinnen und amerikaner
empfinden diese präsidentschaftswahl als
schicksalswahl
es zeichnet sich eine hohe
wahlbeteiligung ab denn so viele bürger
wie nie zuvor haben schon vor dem
wahltag ihr stimmrecht genutzt und per
briefwahl oder persönlich ihren
stimmzettel abgegeben und in diesem jahr
dürfen mehr als 15 millionen junger
amerikaner zum ersten mal wählen
meine kollegin claudia buckenmaier hat
einige von ihnen in arizona getroffen
und sie gefragt ob sie sich donald trump
oder joe biden im weißen haus wünschen
cameron
decker ist 19 jahre alt und macht
wahlkampf für die republikaner seien
heimatstadt ist ihm wichtig er hat sich
die umrisse von arizona gar als tattoos
stechen lassen
an seiner uni sind konservative
studenten wie er in der minderheit
am telefon versucht der wähler zu
gewinnen
das hört sich toll an die jungen
anhänger der republikaner stimmen nicht
in allen us präsident über ein
entscheidender sei die
wirtschaftspolitik ihm gefällt dass es
weniger regulierungen gibt niedrigere
steuern mehr jobs viele neue chancen bei
vanessa beleuchte in der politik sehen
die mehr zutrauen keine eigenen
entscheidungen zu treffen die mir
zutrauen mich als mitglied der
wirtschaftsgesellschaft zu viel soziale
sicherheit lehnt die gruppe ab dass
sozialismus sozialismus als
schreckgespenst
adele und alexa halten das für überholt
gerade unter den jungen sie wollen mehr
soziale gerechtigkeit ihrem alter so
sehen wie sie
wir sind sozusagen aufgewacht besonders
über den sommer hinweg mit der black
lars metter bewegung viele die früher
nicht politisch aktiv werden sagt jetzt
lasst uns wählen gehen die demokraten
egal wie das ist spannend sie sagen ihre
meinungen mehr als zuvor sie sin
verraten wollen einen wandel als ella
diaz studiert gesundheitswesen alexa
basu aldo formation seit der letzten
präsidentschaftswahl sind in den usa 15
millionen junge menschen 18 geworden und
damit wahlberechtigt
ein recht dass viele astra dieses mal
nehmen wollen heißt es in prognosen
auch adele und alexa für sie der
wichtigste grund trump abzuwählen sein
umgang mit der korona pandemie hier ist
paul riederer online-preise der
höchstwahrscheinliche einzige präsident
der die menschen mehr spaltet das
zusammenbringen
selbst jetzt in einer nationalen krise
wäre es nicht an der zeit sich
gegenseitig zu helfen und mitgefühl zu
zeigen aber es ging immer nur um maske
ja oder nein die pandemie als bedrückt
ich finde es enttäuschend ich will ihn
nicht noch mal vier jahre haben
kemmer betonte immer wieder es gebe
vieles das ihn an donald trump störe
aber er wolle pragmatische lösungen und
die sehr nicht bei den demokraten
das fremde pause es geht darum das
politische programm und nicht um seine
rhetorik oder die beschimpfungen die
verteidige ich gar nicht meine erste
wahl nicht nur eine zweite oder dritte
2008 l und alex erkennen dass mit dem
geringeren übel
sie hätten lieber gar nie senders als
kandidatin der demokraten gesehen aber
nur weil es joe biden wurde nicht zur
wahl zu gehen das kommt für die jungen
frauen nicht in frage
beides in slatina auch deshalb falle
ihrer wahl auf die demokraten die
republikaner sind viel schlimmer
ein großer teil ihrer politik schadet
menschen mit niedrigen einkommen und mit
dunkler hautfarbe
okay das ist eine harte aussage habe ich
sehe mich nicht wie ich für einen
republikaner stimmen demokraten sind
nicht perfekt aber zumindest nutzt eure
politik den camerons familie verlor 2008
in der wirtschaftskrise ihr haus erst
vor zwei jahren auch dank trump
steuersenkungen wagten die eltern den
kauf eines neuen hauses in einer
bezahlbaren wohngegend
das hat den studenten der
agrarwirtschaft sehr geprägt auch
deshalb wähle er republikanisch
kapitalismus sicher die reichen werden
immer reicher schuss aber auch die augen
haben um ihr geld kümmern können sogar
seinen größeren prozent
auch ihn belastet wie sehr sein land
gespalten ist
wir haben ein gemeinsames ziel wir
wollen dass es jeden besser geht aber
der weg dahin ist anders wenn wir uns
doch nur zuhören würden das wäre
wirklich wichtig darin sind sich die
jungen leute einig und doch bleibt jeder
in seiner welt ich wünsche mir dass wir
toleranter werden und uns die bedenken
der anderen seite anhören würden und ich
wünsche mir mehr offenheit damit jeder
für sich selbst entscheiden kann
diese freiheit wollen viele andere nicht
geben die zukunft soll besser werden ob
demokratisch oder republikanisch beide
seiten sagen dass sie fest an den sieg
glauben
bei den jungen wählern glauben also
beide seiten fest an einen wahlsieg
aberglauben auch die erfahrenen
republikaner noch daran dass donald
trump allen umfragen zum trotz die
wiederwahl gelingen kann
das möchte ich jetzt peter rau fragen er
war berater von präsident george hw bush
und arbeitet heute für das hudson
institute einen thinktank der der
republikanischen partei nahesteht hallo
peter
würden sie noch geld darauf wetten dass
donald trump wiedergewählt wird
naja vielleicht könnten wir uns
arrangieren aber ich bräuchte gute
wettquoten denn wenn man in
internetportale einsteigt wo man solche
wetten abschließen kann sieht man ja das
ist auch den öffentlichen umfragen
widerspiegeln und da habe ich auch
jüngstes mit einem ziemlich erfahrenen
wahlkämpfer gesprochen er diesmal
involviert ist auf republikanischer
seite
er stand bei den 30 bis 35% chancen noch
zu gerechnet das heißt joe biden ist
ganz klar heute der
haushoher favorit auch wenn noch ein
paar politische bomben vielleicht
gezündet werden können im endspurt
was für bomben könnten auch sein können
sie versprechen das wären wir erfahren
aber es ist doch sehr viel zeit da wir
haben in den letzten zwei jahren sehr
viele politische solidarität erlebt das
heißt der wahlkampf bewegt sich noch es
ist nicht ein ein betonierter ziemlich
strukturierte wahlkampf und da gibt es
vielleicht noch chancen auf die damit
schon was sind aus ihrer sicht die
ursachen dafür dass es für donald trump
im moment so schlecht läuft in den
umfragen ich denke da gibt es zwei
gründe
der erste ist das krone virus in den usa
ist das system so dass die länder und
die bezirke die hauptkompetenz haben für
krisenbekämpfung aber natürlich wenn es
einen so grenzübergreifend in käse gibt
in den usa wie das korn virus schauen
viele wähler zu den präsidenten und da
hat man nicht immer den eindruck gehabt
dass der präsident konstant oder
kohärent argumentiert das zweite ist war
die frage der versöhnung dann dort schon
bist eine art bollwerk gegen eine links
bewegung der demokratischen partei und
diese links bewegung internet innerhalb
der demokratischen partei positioniert
sich als die anti politiker und die
spielen sich fast wähler gegen zu aber
in mitte der gesellschaft gibt es viele
wechselwähler die versöhnung haben
möchten und damals schon ist es nicht
immer gelungen im badisch worte zu
finden und dadurch eben auf diese große
mitte der gesellschaft einzureden
die korona krise hat also die chancen
auf die wiederwahl verringert aber was
hat präsident trump aus ihrer
republikanischen züchtern in seiner
ersten amtszeit gut gemacht ja nicht nur
republikanisch aber ich würde sagen
überparteilich gibt es jetzt einen
konsens und das hat damals schon
wirklich ausgelöst dass man in den
kommenden jahrzehnten eine große
herausforderung für die usa sieht und
das ist die herausforderung von china
das erinnert etwas wie in der
nachkriegszeit in europa ist auch harry
truman damals einen überparteilichen
konsens gegenüber der sowjetunion
forcierte das haben wir mit rampen dann
gibt es einige andere errungenschaften
auf die wir stolz sein kann einen von
konservativen richtern
körperschaftsteuer reform abbau von
regulierungen in der außenpolitik das
erste mal dass es ein friedensvertrag
gibt zwischen israel und den arabern
seit jahrzehnten am anfang seiner
amtszeit sprachen wir noch vom kalifat
desserts das wurde mittlerweile
zertrümmert dass wir durchaus einiges
auf das auch stolz sein darf
gucken wir auf den gegenkandidaten
welche schwächen und welche stärken habe
den joe biden im erst 47 jahre in der
politik das heißt sehr viel erfahrung
das heißt ja schon einiges miterlebt
nicht nur als vizepräsident
vielen europäern bekannt ist sondern
auch als senator aus nevada das heißt er
kennt beide seiten von pennsylvania
avenue den kongress sowie auf das weiße
haus
andererseits ist er schon 47 jahre lang
in der politik und das bedeutet dass er
etwas müde wirkt manchmal labil er
sicherlich mit 77 jahren nicht mehr am
zenit seiner macht man es vielleicht
vorsichtig auszudrücken also positiv und
negatives ist eine langjährige erfahrung
würde ich sagen jetzt in den letzten
tagen vor der wahl geht es ja darum die
wähler zu mobilisieren also auch
tatsächlich zur stimmabgabe zu bewegen
welche wählergruppen sind dann
entscheidend für den wahlausgang
interessanterweise gemessen an das
performance von vier jahren ist damals
schon bei der minderheits wählen gar
nicht so schlecht positioniert der
gouverneur von puerto rico hat jüngst
eine wahlempfehlung für ihn
ausgesprochen amerikaner mit kubanischer
abstammung in florida unterstützung bei
den 60 bis 61
aber wo sind denn sie wird schlechter
geht wo etwas eingebrochen ist erstens
beim pensionisten und zweitens bei
vorstellt wähler insbesondere frauen die
ihnen vor staaten wohnen und da muss
dann trump und das ruder noch zu drehen
etwas überzeugen und aufholen kann ihm
das jetzt noch gelingen es ist ja noch
ein kurzer zeitraum bis zur wahl
ja man spricht davon dass es sehr wenige
unentschlossene wähler noch gibt ich
tendiere eigentlich zur meinung dass
sich noch einige mehr bewegen könnten
dass die amerikaner nicht so wie wir
vielleicht sehr in washington leben von
der politik leben die politische tiere
jedes in und aus verfolgen also es
könnte durchaus noch sein dass das viele
im land gibt die noch nicht wissen ob
sie beiden oder jump wählen werden und
erst im endspurt wirklich die
letztendliche entscheidung treffen
werden vielen dank für den moment liter
wir sprechen uns nachher noch einmal um
das weiße haus zu verteidigen muss
donald trump wiederholen was ihm vor
vier jahren gegen hillary clinton
gelungen ist er muss die stimmen der
weißen arbeiter gewinnen die fühlten
sich damals von den demokraten verraten
und vergessen und heute in pennsylvania
dem start in dem joe biden geboren wurde
hat sich mein kollege stephan niemand
umgehört
ich bin zurück in johnstone pennsylvania
hier schlug einst das herz der
amerikanischen stahlindustrie als wir
die kleinstadt vor den wahlen 2016
besuchten sagten uns die meisten sie
wollten dem außenseiter donald trump
eine chance geben sie fühlten sich von
washington alleingelassen kämpfen mit
arbeitslosigkeit armut und
zukunftsängsten
viele der ehemaligen stahlarbeiter
kehrten den demokraten den rücken
erzählten sie uns vor vier jahren in
ihrer stammkneipe keine leichte
entscheidung für toni kastilien
zuschauen aber der macht sich manchmal
wahnsinnig dann denke ich halt einfach
mal die klappe dann kannst du die wahl
locker gewinnen
vier jahre später treffe ich toni wieder
vor dem stahlwerk in dem er lange
gearbeitet hat er ist zufrieden mit
seinem präsidenten will jump
wiederwählen der wirtschaft er muss noch
wege finden mehr produktionsstopps
zurück in die usa zu holen das ist ja
eines seiner hauptziele
das wird arbeitsplätze schafft und uns
unabhängiger vom ausland machen die
demokraten dagegen so inzwischen so weit
links deren sozialistischen ideen werden
kaum anklang finden bei mehrheit der
amerikaner sonst hans republikaner
wenden sich wieder auf der siegerstraße
für sie gehört in eine reihe mit ronald
reagan
amerika habe endlich wieder einen
präsidenten der auf das volk hört oder
hasst jeder weiß was er denkt weil er
alles ausspricht was ihm durch den kopf
geht und das ist okay für die menschen
juli nimmt uns mit zu einem
motorradausflug auf dem sozius seiner
harley davidson ehefrau rebecca es geht
gen westen durch pennsylvania zügel am
straßenrand deutlich mehr wahlwerbung
für jump als für beiden dabei ist der
demokrat in diesem bundesstaat geboren
die 2016 ist pennsylvania auch heute ein
umkämpfter swing states tonis biker
freunde sind fast alle republikaner
polizisten feuerwehrleute ich frage
warum sie kommt die treue halten
in meinem leben der tut was er
angekündigt hat das beeindruckt mich
sehr
es ist schön mal wieder zu sehen der
worte von trams herausforderer halten
sie nichts
sobald es doch sinn hier trieb region in
seiner agenda der schnuppert immer so
komisch an leuten beiden gehört doch ins
alters dann überrascht mich tonis frau
rebecca ist eine mutige minderheit
ich habe ihn vor vier jahren nicht
gewählt und werde das sagt diesmal nach
tun das ist einfach unheimlich für die
usa doch für die meisten im ländlichen
pennsylvania ist der präsident der
größte dass trump hausprojekt einer
leidenschaftlichen republikanerin leslie
rossi bietet den besuchern tom t shirts
und mützen
sie hofft dass am ende auch alle job die
stimme geben bei dieser wahl hatten sich
schon vier jahre als präsident bewiesen
ich muss hier keine wähler mehr
überzeugen mein job es leicht dieses mal
das team tram pence soll am ruder
bleiben im weißen haus findet auch
familie lecce ich kenne leute die noch
nie republikanisch gewählt haben aber
jetzt für tram stimmen wollen 2016 noch
nervös ich dachte ich dass trump
gewinnen könnte aber diesmal gibt es
keinen zweifel
tom für den pennsylvania siegen und die
ganze wahl gewinnen
viele weiße arbeiter im ländlichen
pennsylvania scheinen trump also die
treue zu halten
doch bei einer anderen wichtigen
wählergruppe hat der präsident
zwischenzeitlich sympathien verspielt
viele rentner haben ihm übelgenommen
dass er die gefahren des koma virus
verharmlosten deshalb ist trump in den
vergangenen wochen mehrfach nach florida
gereist um die herzen der senioren
zurückzuerobern
ob ihm das gelungen ist hat meine
kollegin verena güntner versucht
herauszufinden
es ist ein ganz normaler morgen in
floridas rentner paradies der jugend
treffen sich zum frühsport in einer
heilen welt die am reißbrett nur für sie
entworfen wurde
du willst eine art pittoreskes
disneyland für rentner traditionell
konservativ doch inmitten der idylle
regt sich widerstand
er ist 71 und war sein ganzes leben
unpolitisch hier aber demonstriert er
seit drei jahren jeden tag gut sichtbar
gegen trump und für beiden und misty
rentner gemeinde auf kurzes mehrfaches
hupen das ist ein beiden unterstützer
wer einfach nur lange auf die hypo
drückt ist ein tramp anhänger
inzwischen hat mit kind die ein paar
mitstreiter die ihn schützen für seinen
protest wurde er in der rentner zeitung
gemobbt wurde geschlagen bekam sogar
morddrohungen fast 1200 mal war ich
schon hier draußen die leute in den
village ist vor allem die demokraten
sagen seit drei jahren sitzt er da und
keiner hat ihn bislang gekillt
vielleicht können auch wir es wagen ein
joe biden schild an unserem haus
aufzustellen
es war noch nie einfach demokrat zu sein
in the villages die örtliche zentrale
der demokraten ist außerhalb angesiedelt
innerhalb der kolonie will keiner an sie
vermieten dafür wirkt pappkamerad seien
hier deutlich jünger und trotzdem
spannungen draußen
früher konnten wir nebeneinander liegen
wir haben demokraten oder republikaner
gewählt und konnten doch noch als
freunde miteinander golf spielen das ist
jetzt vorbei
es gibt feindseligkeiten vandalismus
beschimpfungen
es ist sehr hässlich geworden und doch
in diesem wahlkampf bemerken die
demokraten zulauf bei den betagten
wählern viele rentner fühlen sich als
risikopatienten von trumps corona
politik im stich gelassen fürchten um
ihre kranken und rentenversicherung
deswegen traut sich charly steeb noch
ski was und platziert sein beiden schild
zum golfplatz hin
die freunde hier könnten vielleicht
einige golfbälle in meine richtung
schlagen ist wohl zu erwarten aber dafür
bekomme ich ein paar extra ko-spiele
eine packende provokation
ausgerechnet vor der zentrale der
village republikaner die hat räume in
bester zentraler lage nach wie vor
stellen die republikaner die mehrheit im
rentner park allerdings sind sie
zunehmend beunruhigt über diese
aufmüpfigen demokraten
ich mag amerika wie es ist ich will
keine veränderung
ich will nicht dass es sozialistisch
wird oder schlimmer wir mögen dass ein
geschäftsmann am ruder ist
ich finde die demokraten sehr unverblümt
gemein und vulgär
neulich haben wir trump schilder
hochgehalten
und wir haben viele mittelfinger gesehen
und pöbeleien jeden abend seniorentanz
intelligence so jung geblieben die
rentner hier auch rocken
krankenversicherung für alle oder
abschaffung von studiengebühren
forderungen des linken demokratischen
flügel gelten als bedrohlicher
sozialismus
dadurch liefert der sei gut für den
aktienmarkt auf den viele ihrer
altersversorgung stützen
manche würden sich mit den politischen
gegner sogar prügeln
hier gibt es ein paar beiden anhänger
die sind alle stänkerer ich bin dreimal
schon fast verhaftet worden ein kerl hat
sich über meine fragen lustig gemacht
ein anderer über mister trump ich habe
gesagt lasst uns nach hinten gehen wir
können das unter uns regeln
ich bin ein machen wir können reden aber
du zeigst mir nicht den mittelfinger und
sachs zur hölle mit mister trump das
gibt es hier nicht der später aktivist
mit gmp und seine mitstreiter haben
dennoch nicht vorzuweisen
dass die wahl in ihrem sinne entschieden
ist joe biden vip in den hintern treten
joe biden wird gewinnen
dann werde ich die nächsten paar jahre
mit einem neuen schild rumfahren mit der
aufschrift village demokraten sind hier
um zu bleiben
ich will dass diese leute wissen wir
lassen uns nicht mehr von ihnen
herumschubsen mit stolzem
altersstarrsinn will at morgen wieder
hierher kommen so schnell wird wohl
keine ruhe einkehren in flocken dass
rentner edel könnte es passieren dass
donald trump die wahl verliert aber sich
weigert aus dem weißen haus auszuziehen
diese hypothetische frage ist nicht ganz
abwegig denn der präsident hat immer
wieder offen gelassen ob er eine
wahlniederlage anerkennen würde
immer wieder warnt er vor betrug bei der
briefwahl bei einem knappen ergebnis
könnten unruhen ausbrechen befürchten
beobachter denn eine reihe von rechten
milizen scheint bereit trumps macht
notfalls auch mit waffengewalt zu
verteidigen
um herauszufinden wie groß diese gruppen
wirklich sind und was sie antreibt sind
wir nach saint louis im us bundesstaat
missouri gereist
[Musik]
wenn die fäuste fliegen werden wir
wieder eure knochen brechen
[Musik]
mit diesem song text stimmen sich die
profis von saint-louis auf ihre
versammlung alex firmen ist 28 jahre alt
und arbeitet für einen schlüssel dient
als er vor drei jahren zum ersten mal
hierher kam zogen die neat raubbau es
sofort in ihren bann
das ist gefallen hat ist dass wilde die
lust am rauchen der stolz dass alles
gibt ja einen schub oft hatte ich das
gefühl gehabt mich dafür schämen zu
müssen ein weißer mann zu sein als ich
das hier sah fand ich das super
um mitglied der umstrittenen rechten
bruderschaft zu werden muss man nicht
nur ein mann sein sondern sich auch dazu
bekennen die westliche zivilisation für
überlegen zu halten
die meisten hier sind grundsätzlich
gegen die sogenannte politische
korrektheit und gegen einwanderung
das problem an der demokratie ist dass
immigranten hereinkommen besteht die
gefahr dass sie illegal bürger werden
und diese alten linken ansichten aus
mexiko mitbringen dann dürfen sie auch
noch wählen und verändern amerika für
seinen harten kurs in der
einwanderungspolitik verehren die braut
us-präsident trump das gilt auch für
ihre freundinnen trumps warnungen vor
einem möglichen wahlbetrug sind hier auf
fruchtbaren boden gefallen nation raider
würde seinen präsidenten notfalls
verteidigen patrioten wie mich um zu
sagen wir werden wahlergebnisse nicht
einfach hinnehmen wenn etwas faul ist
wenn wir auf legale weise aktiv werden
können würde ich das zu 100% tun
heute ziehen die proteus und ihre
unterstützerinnen aber erstmal gegen
eine corona masken pflicht in den
in der innenstadt von saint-louis haben
sie zum protest aufgerufen
doch es kommt kaum jemand schuld daran
seien facebook und twitter die ihre
seiten gesperrt hätten erklären sie und
bürgerrechtsorganisationen stufen die
braut boys als hasserfüllt und
rassistisch ein
enrique tello widerspricht dieser
darstellung der usa chef der braut boss
ist stolz darauf dass präsident trump
sich in der ersten tv-debatte nicht
sofort von der organisation distanziert
hat er weiß dass wir keine
rechtsextremisten sind und er hat gesagt
wir sollen uns bereithalten damit meinte
trump wohl nur dass wir zu ihm halten
sollen das haben wir seit dem ersten tag
getan weil wir konservativ sind tram
stellt das amerikanische volk an die
erste stelle
darum unterstützen wir ihnen die
mitgliederzahlen seien seit streams
äußerungen deutlich gestiegen erklärt
terry weltweit gebe es rund 22.000 braut
boys vor einer bar erleben wir am abend
das aufnahmerituale für ein neumitglied
keine sogenannten brüder verpassen dem
man so lange faustschläge bisher fünf
müsli sorten aufgezählt hat
ich fühle mich großartig als teil einer
gemeinschaft unschlagbar in der bar geht
es hoch her
die braut boys hier bezeichnen sich
selbst wörtlich als laufclub für
patrioten
doch sie präsentieren sich nicht immer
so harmlos
wir konfrontieren den usa chef der
profis mit einem foto darauf hält er ein
plakat mit der aufschrift nur ein toter
kommunist ist ein guter kommunist kerio
rechtfertigt sich teile seiner familie
seien in kuba von kommunisten ermordet
worden
kommunismus hat keinen platz in amerika
genauso wenig wie faschismus wenn ich
sage ein guter kommunist ist ein toter
kommunist dann meine ich das so ob
jemand das als provokation versteht oder
nicht ist mir egal
als kommunisten betrachtet terry neben
der antifa und der blätter bewegung auch
teile der demokratischen partei vereint
gegen den feind die prob boys sind
bester stimmung
sie genießen die aufmerksamkeit die sie
durch die aussagen des präsidenten
bekommen haben am dritten november
wollen sie wieder feiern
sie sind überzeugt dass donald trump die
wiederwahl gelingt fragen wir nach peter
rauch vom hudson institute wieder für
wie wahrscheinlich halten sie es dass es
tatsächlich zu einem auszeichnungs chaos
und vielleicht sogar unruhen im land
kommt wenn es ein sehr knappes
wahlergebnis geben würde
ja es ist schon eine logistische
herausforderung für die usa inmitten
einer pandemie eine so groß angelegte
briefwahl das hatten wir bis dahin und
nicht in der geschichte der republik da
kommt noch dazu dass natürlich dann noch
schauen sehr viele emotionen heraus
folgt wir haben auch aufgrund der
digitalen transformation sehr viel
polarisierung im lande unter gerade
deswegen könnte man sagen dass sich die
situation zuspitzt ich bin trotzdem der
meinung aber dass es eine bestimmte
demokratische gepflogenheit in den usa
gibt und dass man hier genügend
logistischen fähigkeiten hat um den
bürgern und bürgerinnen zu überzeugen
dass wir ja eine mehr oder wenige faire
wahl hinter uns haben auch wenn es in
einzelnen bereichen vielleicht nicht
immer perfekt läuft
manche beobachter waren sogar vor einem
bürgerkrieg halten sie diese warnung für
berechtigt oder für übertrieben so ich
halte das für völlig übertrieben ich
denke wir sind zwar ein schmelztiegel
mit unterschiedlich
konfessionen und hautfarben aber nicht
wirklich eine multikulturelle
gesellschaft das heißt wir haben eine
leitkultur wir haben eine bestimmte
korrosion wir haben einen zusammenhalt
und umso mehr würde ich sagen dass wir
einen trainer und 44 jahren ins
geschichte eigentlich ziemlich viel
erreicht haben als amerikaner wir sind
dann die weltspitze katapultiert und
viele bürger und bürger wissen gegensatz
zu 18 61 als sie ein bürgerkrieg gab
dass die usa mit diesem system sehr viel
erreicht hat das wäre sehr leichtsinnig
dass von heute auf morgen einfach zu
zerschlagen
die außenpolitik spielte in
amerikanischen präsidentschaftswahl
kämpfen traditionell keine große rolle
in diesem jahr ist das auch so trotzdem
fragen sich die menschen in deutschland
natürlich was eine mögliche präsident
biden für die bundesrepublik bedeuten
würde was kann man da erwarten weil
würde deutschland umarmen das ist ganz
klar eine enge beraterin von ihnen hat
schon vor jahren dass er den ersten 100
150 tagen nach europa ist insbesondere
deutschland um dort ein signal zu setzen
er würde das pariser klimaschutz
abkommen unterschreiben er will auch
wieder in die
weltgesundheitsorganisation einsteigen
aber es wäre auch für deutschland nicht
so einfach denn mit dieser umarmung
würden auch etliche forderungen kommen
und wenn deutschland sich nicht bewegen
kann und mit den demokraten zusammen
kommen kann da muss man sich fragen was
ist übrig vom transatlantischen bündnis
man kann ich mit schaumburg den
republikanern man kann auch nicht mit
beiden unter demokraten das wäre dann
schon eine ziemlich schlechtes zeugnis
für die transatlantische beziehung das
heißt sozusagen der bewegung trump dass
man sich nicht mit den usa zusammen
raufen kann wäre dann weg da würde in
die luft aufgelöst werden und dann
müsste man mit den demokraten schon
können sie haben gerade von forderungen
gesprochen dieser breiten stellen würde
woran denken sie da geht es darum nato
gibt es da vielleicht auch im handel
genau da geht es erstens um eine
ausgewogene handelspolitik da geht es um
sicherheit zur verteidigungs
investitionen legen um eine gemeinsame
linie gegenüber
die chinesen in der handelspolitik das
sind alles bereiche wo deutschland bis
jetzt hat können jump and reichen weil
mannschaftlich kann so das argument aber
mit beiden wäre das argument an weg und
da gibt es schmerzliche schritte und
konzessionen die man nehmen müsste um
die liberale welt ordnung aufrecht zu
erhalten also auch joe biden würde von
deutschland verlangen zwei prozent des
bruttoinlandsprodukts für verteidigung
auszugeben sicherlich mehr investieren
die kapazitäten und fähigkeiten
sollte donald trump die wiederwahl
gelingen was wir von ihm den
außenpolitisch noch zu erwarten
ich denke den weg kennen wir ja so er
würde einerseits sicherlich weiterhin
der kirche zumindest die militärische
sicherheit europas garantieren und
gewährleisten
aber mit der spannung wie in der
vergangenheit auch gespielt hat wo er
damit etwas genügend ambiguität stolz so
dass europa sich bewegt mehr zu
investieren mehr fähigkeit aufzubauen
und sina handelspolitik möchte er mehr
eine ausgewogene politische
zusammenarbeit dass das
handelsbilanzüberschuss zum beispiel
deutschlands sind etwas verringert wir
sind uns in den letzten vier jahren
etwas entwickeln in diesem bereich
insbesondere weil die usa sie so je nach
fokussierte aber für acht jahre trump
ist das für mich schwer vorstellbar dass
man permanent sich aus dem weg gehen
kann das heißt man müsse überlegen in
berlin in brüssel auch in paris wie
würde man mit damals schon umgehen und
wie würde man ein gemeinsames
transatlantisches außenpolitisches
konzept aufstellen
die deutsche industrie zieht hat ja
immer vor den auto zählen glauben sie
dass die im falle einer zweiten amtszeit
kommen das ist schwer zu sagen also was
sind da noch chance kopf vorgeht das war
es eigentlich nur download trump aber
letztendlich ist der ja dafür bekannt
mit hebel zu spielen als immer wieder
auch angedeutet und dann ein geständnis
und konzessionen von anderen
abzuverlangen also das wäre durchaus
denkbar dass er rhetorisch mit diesen
schritt spielt so dass deutschland
bereit ist in einer handels gespräche
und verhandlungen zu werden gucken wir
noch mal auf die innenpolitik im inneren
kämpfen die usa mit großen strukturellen
problemen wie rassismus an überforderten
gesundheitssystemen und einer großen
kluft zwischen arm und reich hätte ein
präsident beiden überhaupt das potenzial
diese großen strukturellen themen
anzugehen oder sind die möglichkeiten
eines präsidenten begrenzt er ist sehr
groß ist wenn man schon in deutschland
große unterschiede zwischen münchen und
hamburg in der berlin verspürt können
sie sich vorstellen dass zwischen sagen
wir alabama und california auch große
unterschiede vor allem sind
nichtsdestotrotz würde ich sagen dass
ein präsident mit die richtige form
schritte mehr flexibilität in der
bildung kriminalität zu bekämpfen und so
weiter sehr viel auch für minderheiten
bewegen kann man hat schon mehrfach in
der vergangenheit erleben zb sich in
lubmin ist ration von george hw bush
gearbeitet habe gab es ein fake basic
mini dänische läuft hat man sich auf die
kirchen gelehnt so dass man in afro
amerikanische nachbarschaften auch
drogen bekämpft dass man dort auch
zivilgesellschaft fördert usw
ich glaube mit den richtigen schritten
kann die exekutive auch von den
rednerpult aus sehr viel bewegen
letzte frage zum schluss was ist ihr
tipp für den ausgang der wahl
also ich glaube joe biden schaut im
moment so aus als ob er die wahl
gewinnen wird aber das ausmaß seines
wahlsieges wird auch entscheidend sein
denn letztendlich gibt es in
amerikanischen politik eine schlepptau
effekt es ist ja nicht nur der präsident
dazu bestellt sondern auch etliche
senatoren die mehrheit der republikaner
ist auf dem spiel im senat und wenn joe
biden leicht mit einem leichten
vorsprung gewinnt dann kann man davon
ausgehen dass die republikaner im senat
halten wenn es ein großer erdrutschsieg
wird ja dann wird nicht nur der senat
vollen gehen sondern wird auch etliche
abgeordneten sitze verlieren wenn dann
und schon gewinnt dann kann man davon
ausgehen dass das senats nicht nur für
die rega gerettet ist eine
möglicherweise auch ausgebaut wird
pedro vielen dank für diesen ausblick
auf die präsidentschaftswahl und für
ihre wertvollen einschätzung danke wir
blicken noch einmal ins innenleben der
amerikanischen seele polizeigewalt gegen
schwarze ist hier leider kein neues
phänomen aber in diesem wahljahr kam es
nach dem tod von george floyd zu
besonders heftigen ausschreitungen und
friedlichen massenprotesten und um die
black lips matter bewegung
gleichzeitig wurden schwarze amerikaner
von der korona krise besonders schwer
getroffen
in new orleans konnten wir erleben
welche stimmung bei vielen schwarzen
wählern kurz vor der
präsidentschaftswahl herrscht
juli die stadt die amerika der big easy
nennt sucht wieder nach ihrer
leichtigkeit viele band treten nur noch
auf der straße auf denn dutzende musik
clubs haben den corona locker und nicht
überlegt cornell andrews findet dass
präsident trump wegen seines schlechten
krisenmanagements mitverantwortlich sein
wählen gehen will er trotzdem nicht es
wird sich nie etwas ändern egal wer
präsident ist das war doch schon immer
so es geht nicht um uns sondern nur um
politik
sie ändern ein paar regeln
unterschreiben ein paar gesetze und so
aber wir auch immer präsident ist es
wird nichts für die minderheiten getan
die schwarze bevölkerung in den usa
traditionell mehrheit nicht die
demokraten hier meldet man sich an um am
dritten november wählen zu können
terol platz sieht will unbedingt eine
zweite amtszeit von präsident trump
verhindern
zum ersten mal seit 23 jahren wird er
dafür an die urne gehen
lange hatte er geglaubt das ja gar nicht
wählen dürfen rocket man sagte mir das
ginge nicht weil ich eine verurteilung
in meiner akte hatte
aber das war eine irreführende
informationen denn ich war nie im
gefängnis
erst jetzt habe ich herausgefunden dass
sich all die jahre hätte wählen können
und werden sollen
die verbreitung von solchen
irreführenden informationen sei kein
zufall sondern habe methode davon ist
diese wahlrechts aktivistin überzeugt
die republikanische partei versuche hier
in louisiana systematisch die
stimmabgabe zu verhindern
das richtig sich besonders gegen
schwarze wähler
viele wahllokale in schwarzen
nachbarschaften wurden geschlossen das
gleiche passiert in gegenden mit vielen
älteren leuten die keine
transportmöglichkeiten haben um zu
anderen wahllokalen zu kommen
zum wellen aufgerufen wird in diesem
gottesdienst der wandel wird kommen
singen sie
der pianist als adwords stammt aus einem
problemviertel von new orleans die musik
habe ihn immer davor bewahrt in
schwierigkeiten zu geraten
trotzdem werde er behandelt wie ein
krimineller als afroamerikaner mit
rastalocken werde ich diskriminiert zb
wenn die polizei mich immer wieder an
ich zeige dann meine arbeitsnachweise
dass ich viel für die gemeinde und die
kirche tue für eine gemeinnützige
organisation arbeiters und kindern
kostenlosen musikunterricht geben um ein
zeichen gegen rassismus zu setzen hat
der pastor einen autokorso organisiert
mehr als 60 gemeindemitglieder neben
teil werde ich der nächste sein schreibt
dieser kleine junge auf sein schild und
meint damit die polizeigewalt gegen
schwarze
[Musik]
hinter der bilderbuch kulisse von new
orleans werden viele probleme sichtbar
mit denen die schwarze bevölkerung
überall im land zu kämpfen hat nicht nur
in diesen wochen vor der
präsidentschaftswahl
es wird wieder abend auf der bourbon
street
die musiker geben sich alle mühe doch
the big easy klingt schwermütig wie
amerika in zukunft klingt wird davon
abhängen wer im weißen haus den ton
angibt weil umfragen auch irren können
steht zum jetzigen zeitpunkt nur eines
fest es wird spannend in der wahlnacht
werden wir hier bei phoenix für sie
berichten vielen dank für ihr interesse
[Musik]